hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber it's a it's
quite an interesting game I was played
in Dortmund in 1996 between gata Kamsky
and Anatoly Karpov and in 1966
well gotta come ski has always been a
strong player but in 1996 he actually
managed to get to the finals of the
video World Chess Championship okay cuz
part when the short weren't playing at
that time because they were in their PCA
or organization since they had a little
argument with fidei but nevertheless an
extremely strong player at that time
already it at the age of 22 so this is
round one of the tournament in Dortmund
and he faces Karpov he has the white
pieces and comes he opens the game with
E for Karpov plays c6 he was for the
caro-kann d4 d5 Knight to D to the D
captures Knight captures this is the
main line of the caro-kann and Knight to
d7 Karpov goes for the Karpov variation
of the caro-kann Knights the g5 now
Knight the G to f6 and Bishop to d3 we
have E six Knight 1 to f3 Bishop to d6
Queen to e2 all standard developing
moves h6 Knight to e4 Knight captures
Queen captures and now Knight to f6 we
have Queen to h4 and here you can see
that comes his plan so far has been
these bishops are eyeing the Kings side
the knight is ready also to join the
attack the Queen is already aggressively
placed on h4 so carpet really has to
find the plan here so what options does
he have he can maybe decide to play Ruby
g8 pulled g5 and create some sort of a
attack on the King side himself but he
still doesn't know where come ski will
castle and playing something like b6
Bishop to b7 might be kind of slow
sorry so he has to find an idea here and
the move Karpov played here was actually
King to the e7 and although this looks
like a really bizarre move I really
believe this was a prepared prior to the
game probably by geller himself
he just suggested it the Karpov but king
37 seems to be the strongest move in
this position and at least it's my
engines favorite suggestion
so Karpov played King Teresa came to be
seven here but let's just see what
happens if he castles gasoline here
isn't really an option as we mentioned
these two bishops are aggressively
eyeing the King side so Bishop captures
on h6 here is an automatic after G
capture screen captures you already
busted the King side a bishop for two
points so that's not really an issue
it's not really even a sacrifice and
look black still has problems developing
this Knight can't move there is a
checkmate threat on h7 so let's say
Queen e7 now comes ninety five you can't
capture the night because after pawn
captures you're not gonna be able to
move the night as the checkmate on h7 is
still there so after something like c5
now Queen checks King moves and now g5
again G for threatening g5 this will
force the nice night out of f6 you can
never play rook to g8 as Queen to h6
will follow check night after night
blocks to h7 the bishop is covering h7
again this will be checkmate so let's
say rook to d8 making some room for the
Queen but now Queen checks King moves
and now g5 kicking the night away
clinging to f8 offering the trade of
Queens and also the knight on f6 but
after Queen to h4 now the night again
can't move because of the threat threat
of checkmate on h7 but it has to move so
blocking walking checkmate Queen
captures and now Queen to g7 defending
checkmate
but sorry but now simply g6 Bishop
captures night and now pawn captures on
f7 this is what check King can go to the
H file if you capture with the Queen
then Queen to g5 check picks up the rook
would check other idea is king to f8
maybe but even after talking to a fate
you simply recap from me v you can
Castle queenside room g1 is coming and
the black is completely busted
so after King 2 is that after this move
castling isn't really an option so
Karpov decided King to e7 so a very nice
move
we have a knife to e5 by Kamsky and this
is basically offering upon because the
knight can be captured even though he
captures an e5 is coming but it's not
like black doesn't have any options here
so Karpov accepted the challenge he will
give up the bishop pair to grab a pawn
we have Bishop captures pawn captures
and uh pinning the night and here we
have Queen to a5 check c3 blocking and
now Queen captures on e5 with check and
Bishop to e3 blocking check so Karpov is
up a pawn but comes he has the bishop
pair and the King is somewhat awkwardly
placed on e7 so it's a pretty much an
equal position Karpov loves his extra
pawn and comes close the two bishops for
the attack so be 6 by Karpov we have
queenside castle and now g5 queen to a
for attacking the c6 pawn and now c5 now
carpel will be able to play either
Bishop to d7 or Bishop to d7 depending
on what Kamsky plays and it kind of
blocks this dark square Bishop here so a
lot of good ideas about c5 rook HD 1 now
come ski is still down upon but he
mobilized all of his pieces and all of
them are on very nice first both rooks
are occupying the the defiled e-file the
bishops are ready to jump into the game
and here a couple plays Bishop to d7
attacking comes his queen we have Queen
to a3 and now developing the rook rook H
to be a unfortunately for Kamsky he
doesn't have any good discoveries with
this Bishop you can't capture anything
because carpet will seem to capture the
bishop or the Queen you can play the d2
but this is just silly you play you put
a bishop on on a silly square so here
comes to plays g3 now preparing better
to f4 but Karpov simply moves the Queen
Queen c7 so Bishop to d4 now the bishop
can be capture of course as the point is
pinned the queen is here the king is on
e7 Bishop 3:8 now we have pink the b1
and rook to d5 now
f-for rook a to the eighth now Karpov
develops all of his pieces he doubles up
rooks on the D file we have Bishop the
c2 and now rook five 2d six now this
this pawn is no longer pinned and carpet
will be able to capture the bishop so
Bishop captures on f6 King captures on
f6 and now F captures and g5 we have h
captures on g5 and now rook captures on
d6 rook captures and c4 preparing this
Queen to jump into the game King back to
e7 by Karpov and now Queen to e3
attacking the g5 pawn f6 defending and
now h4 so Kamsky is still down upon but
he manages to create a passed pawn on
the Queen side on the Kings side
G captures pawn captures and this this
passed pawn definitely is a compensation
enough for being a pawn down Queen to d7
we have Queen to h6 now II five point to
h5 now comes kid pushes his past pawn as
you all know test points must be pushed
Queen to g4 we have cling to h7 check
into b8 and h6 now pushing the passed
pawn even further
I forgot to mention it was unmoved 33
the first time comes he pushed the pawn
to h4 it was at that moment that comes
he actually offered the draw to Karpov
but Karpov declined the draw saying that
the only compensation comes ahead in the
position was actually the bishop pair
now that he lost that he still didn't
manage to grab a pawn back so he's down
upon and he doesn't really have the
bishop pair so there is no reason to
take a draw here and Karpov said that
black has better winning chances in that
position it was in the position when h4
was played so rook to d2
attacking the bishop somewhat preparing
some moves here and here we have Queen
to f5 offering a trade of Queens we have
Queen captures Bishop captures and here
Karpov makes a pretty pretty big mistake
the idea for Karpov is rook to h2
and after h7 is played that rock will
that rock will always prevent this pond
from being pushed forward it will be
very hard for Kamsky to make anything of
this past pawn but but this next move
careful plays Bishop to d7 is actually a
terrible blunder and I don't want you to
pause the pause the video here and find
the move that can't ski missed in the
game because in the game can't see
didn't take advantage of this terrible
blunder but I'm sure you'll be able to
find it as they were both in pretty
big-time trouble here but you know you
can pause the video you have all the
time you like so feel free to find it
for those of you who did post the video
and who were able to find the move
congratulations you're a great player
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show the move both Karpov and Kamsky
missed was actually King to c1 and kink
the c1 wins the game why does King to c1
win the game
well this rook has to protect the bishop
on d7 and I will explain why when one
idea is that after we play something
like rook to d4 then comes Bishop to e4
blocking the rook from coming to h4 and
now the pawn is coming forward rook has
the capture and you simply capture it
and it's a it's a winning position after
Bishop attacks rook you simply prepared
to push bishop blocks now becomes rook
to g5 g 4 and after bishop moves again
and now comes rock check King moves and
now h7 and there is no defense black
must capture and now comes King to g7
check King moves and rook captures so
this is completely winning and on the
other hand after King to c1 if you don't
move the rook through the D file if you
play something like rook to h2
immediately going for the pawn then
unfortunately comes rook to d1 and now
the bishop on d7 is pinned so that's why
Bishop to d7 is a terrible blunder but
fortunately for Karpov and unfortunately
podcast Kamsky they both missed it so
after Bishop to d7 by Karpov and another
thing is you don't really expect Karpov
blunder like this so he didn't really
even look for King to see one Bishop to
g6 was played here rook to h2 going for
that passed pawn we have h7 King to e7
Bishop to d3 now Bishop to e6 rook to g1
we have f5 rook the g7 check out King
moves to f6
rook does capture on a 7 but now as you
can see it's pretty much impossible to
promote to this passed pawn as the rook
will be guarding the queening square
that is h8 and this Bishop is a light
square bishop so the bishop can't really
help with the cleaning of the pawn and
now carpel will start pushing his own to
passed pawns that are connected afore we
have Bishop to e2 f4 comes now b3 f3 now
again attacking the bishop bishop to d1
and now Bishop to f5 threatening a
discovery here so King to see one now
comes
Bishop captures on h7 there was really
nothing it comes we do here to prevent
the loss of this pawn rook to b7 and now
comes King e5 rook captures some b6 and
after rook captures an a2 in this
position you gotta come ski resigned the
game and as you can see there's there's
nothing he can do here it's very simple
King King comes to a4 even if the rook
tries to check Bishop to a5 prevents the
check and then Karpov simply pushes the
victory so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said it was a
game from round 1 and Karpov started
this tournament with a victory it was an
eight-player tournament and Karpov won
this tournament with 5 and a half points
out of 7 one whole point ahead of
Vladimir Kramnik
chronic was second with 4 points so a
great victory in this game and a great
victory in this tournament for Karpov
good job unemployment that King to e7
move that was there was really something
in that position I haven't found out for
sure but I'm I'm guessing Geller found
that and prepared it for Karpov and yeah
a very nice game especially if you're a
current player I'm very interested if
maybe you've employed this idea
came to e7 in your own games so yeah I
would like to thank Paris fencing for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon
probably would another classic and PS I
am taking suggestions what do you want
for the 1000 100,000 subscriber giveaway
video see you soon